this morning an ohio couple has filed a
lawsuit against bowling green state
university claiming that the school was
negligent in the fraternity hazing death
of their son an autopsy found that
20-year-old stone folds died get this
with a blood alcohol level more than
four times the legal driving limit mark
strassman reports now with our columbus
affiliate wbns on the folt's new mission
to end hazing
stone fultz died needlessly after
drinking the equivalent of 17 shots of
whiskey you're just in such traumatic
shock sherry and corey fultz stone's
parents is there any way to describe
the hole in your heart
it's exactly that it's a hole in your
heart the pain never goes away
prosecutors say that last year brothers
at pike pi kappa alpha fraternity told
pledges like fultz to drink a liter of
whiskey each
his roommate found him unconscious
do you see his chest rising up and down
no not right now
okay he's blue
yeah okay then he there's a good chance
he's not breathing his final three days
were in a coma
eight fraternity members were convicted
of a variety of charges including
reckless homicide at least three will
spend time behind bars
these are young men and women they need
supervision
and that's where
the lack was with
the university the false lawsuit claims
bowling green actively promoted its
greek organizations but turned a blind
eye to hazing we believe it's a case of
negligence but i also believe it's a
case of recklessness without
accountability there is no chance of
reform 100 percent they have a legal and
a moral responsibility to protect these
kids in a statement to cbs news bowling
green said stone fultz's death was a
tragedy however this lawsuit is
meritless ignores that we have actively
enforced our anti-hazing policy and
undermines our continued efforts to
eradicate hazy
after fultz's death the school
permanently banned pi kappa alpha ohio's
public universities adopted a zero
tolerance policy toward hazing and a new
state law made hazing a felony
not enough for the fultz family we will
do whatever it takes to not let this
happen to another
young man or woman or family to go
through the nightmare that we live every
single day for cbs mornings mark
strassman in atlanta